boys
and
and girls good though the people who uh
yeah all right guys so we got the god of
war ragnarok official reveal trailer
here today came out a couple of days ago
from the time i'm uploading this video
the way to watch this trailer i did play
god of war like i think a little over a
year ago so it's been quite a while it's
on by no means like an expert on all the
mythology that it's covering or even the
game itself but i did quite enjoy it a
hell of a lot you know what i really
remember from my experience with it i
remember being surprisingly good not
having difficulty with the boss levels
but any of the levels where it involved
like fighting a wide variety of people
on one stage would just
like send me into a frenzy that that was
the main thing i remember from my
experience is just being pissed off on
those stages however
i'm very much excited for this game it's
one of the main reasons why i've been
hunting down a ps5 they're mailing these
games but start making more consoles man
anywho let's see what's going on here
people
[Music]
it is exciting to see you back
the time is running out
the prophecy saying remember winter
leads to ragnarok older boy
my story doesn't end hiding in these
woods
i should be out there find out who i am
[Music]
anywhere
god this looks great
for a moment and start yes like a
gentleman
you seem
[Music]
hell yeah
yes
center
this combat man
are you coming with us
holy [ __ ]
he's
he'll get your answer soon enough
okay i saw uh like i was on twitter
there was like an ign ign had like a
poster of her and i was like i gotta i
gotta wait to watch the trailer so i
don't know i don't know who that woman
is but okay so tears alive that's
established
and he is
[ __ ] master
he's so much bigger than i thought he
would be
all right okay let's chat about this for
a little bit all right i'm on twitter
right now on ig heads post okay here we
go this woman is
agra uh
please just tell me how to pronounce it
all right
the mate of loki and mother of monsters
pardon norse mythol at least in norse
mythology google good to know and loki
have multiple wives and then oh we gotta
look at thor here
oh [ __ ] look at him
he is
he's a beast that is not chris hemsworth
and i'm all for it hell yeah that looks
awesome he looks intimidating i love the
voice work that he got him the little
bit of voice worth he got of him in the
trailer was awesome are you a calm and
reasonable person this trailer
completely delivers on all ends i mean
from like the gameplay what's cool about
a trailer like this is that a lot of
times you'll see like cinematic trailers
and there'll be some gameplay in there
but often times the gameplay is still
just part of cut scenes if you play the
first god of war you know that's what
the gameplay is like and it is only
going to get better i love the part
where they're riding with the wolves
that looked awesome all the snowy
landscapes looked incredible you mean
you got the return here of characters
like freya mamir you got the dwarves you
got a trace here so i mean i don't know
how much time has passed here but he's
definitely older sounds like a different
voice i imagine to be a different voice
actor because remember at the game
awards it was like a little boy i don't
know who else they got but that's one of
the highlights of god of war is that
father-son dynamic but that line there
that was a hell of a lie what was that
let me play it back stop stop thinking
like a father for a moment and start
thinking like a general what a quote
definitely forms for a different dynamic
so much of that relationship in the
first one was this boy wanting a father
and then this time around he wants
really the the war side of his father to
be unleashed demanding the general
within him comes out but of course you
know i think like the big reveal that's
why they say before the end they talk so
much about tier in the first one he's
supposed to be dead but he's clearly
around and he's alive and i love the
design of him i think he looks
intimidating as hell and uh it was a was
a welcome surprise i'm surprised they
show him in the trailer actually the
trailer starts off with saying tyra's
dead and then we gotta go look for him
and so i thought that we were just gonna
go back down that path at least giving
the audience like hope and alluding to
the fact that you might see tear for
real this time around by no means is
that something that ruins the experience
of the game of hell you don't even see
thor in action here in the trailer you
just hear his voice and while they
release the character design that's
still something to look forward to and
you know how expansive and crazy the
world and lore is of this game so
obviously we're gonna get so much more
story to unpack here what i loved most
about it was while it honed in so much
on the adventure the expansion of the
mythology while they don't 100 percent
honor them i'm gonna act like i know all
the mythology like norse mythology and
all that stuff but i i'm aware that they
at least take their own spin and
iterations on it i'm excited to see what
spins they take on it but it still seems
to be focused on the father-son dynamic
at its core which is a big part of what
made the first game or not the first
game but you know the the one from
before work so well yeah i just like
love skimming this trailer it's like
even even right at the beginning when
he's carrying the deer inside and the
way the antlers have this like
silhouette just provides like that loki
symbolism to it so i'm not sure how old
atreus is supposed to be in this game
but it seems like he's not just older
because he's older because time has
passed it seems as if though you know
like his uh
his whole personality is shifting and
you get sort of this like teen angst
vibe from him a prime age where you're
still a child but you want to be
an adult you know what i mean i love how
kratos is
obviously so resistant towards going
down this path because he's still after
after the journey he went on in the last
game he still doesn't want to
unleash or go back into that wrathful
side within him it's also being a father
towards atreus he obviously wouldn't
want a trace to keep going down this
path because he doesn't want atreus to
become what he once was i feel like the
the central conflict of this game the
real corn heart of it will still be
fully on display as it is greatly
affected throughout this journey how
that first game they were so distant in
terms of father and son and it was about
them really forming that bond towards
the end of the game this one seems like
the path might lead them to become
distant again because they have two very
different sets of
you know views on how they should
proceed i'm very much looking forward
mainly to that it's like the
storytelling element of it is like my
favorite part hey you know there's
there's got realms and [ __ ] in here so
there's gonna be a lot more to unpack we
got uh freaking asgard to deal with and
i imagine i imagine we'll get odin this
time around
hell yeah
nipple chills all the way war isn't the
only way but it makes for a damn good
game kratos guys what do you think about
this trailer leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell hit that
like button hey let's do it
now if there's one person i would love
to go into war
with if i needed someone by my side it
would be andrew hayes short stocky
aggressive fella but also if we need to
navigate the lands this guy is one hell
of a charming dude you're the one i want
to shout out for this video man you've
been a longtime supporter of our channel
long time follower and also you've been
one of our longest patrons and what you
need
someone by your side in the battlefield
is loyalty and we got that with you dude
but just so you know if there was ever
people shooting an arrow at me i'd
definitely use your body as a shield and
i feel like you'd be okay with that
that's one of the main reasons i love
you man you're willing to sacrifice your
life to keep me around and i'm willing
to sacrifice your life to keep me alive
too
so be a good boy
and
take the hit
[Music]